v.org
hi good evening i'm tony clark from the
carter presidential library i'm really
glad you all are here
this is really a special night for us
because
the book itself is is perfect for the
kind of authors and and book topics that
we like to have here at the carter
presidential library because it talks
about congress and the president and how
they work together even when they don't
necessarily agree on on things in fact
it was funny i was looking up
talk that a speech that president carter
gave in naming a building in beaumont
texas after congressman brooks and one
of the things the president said at the
time was he as a new president thought
well if i just have one congressman
that disagrees with me i'm the president
of the united states that's no big deal
and then he found out that that one
congressman was jack brooks and that was
a
big deal
but
it talks about how presidents in
congress work together and i think at
this time it is very important that we
we hear that uh that message about how
they work together and we're especially
pleased tonight
to have congressman jack brooks son
jeb here with us jeb has worked in the
financial industry excuse me in all size
companies for
more than three decades he started his
career at citibank in taiwan rose to
vice president of citigroup's
international securities in london he's
currently the managing partner of
pinewood trading fund and is the
chairman of the jack brooks foundation
which provided the wonderful reception
for us tonight so please join me in
welcoming and thanking
jeb brooks
[Applause]
and thank you so much tony for that kind
introduction we are all grateful uh to
you and the carter library and museum
for your generosity in hosting us this
evening
with events like this i'm grateful that
example can continue to inspire people
for years to come
jack brooks devoted his life to this
country
first as a marine
then by serving his constituents as
their representative
serving his constituents long enough to
serve alongside 10 u.s presidents
but the best one of course was president
jimmy carter
so it's truly
truly an honor to have
all y'all here to share with you this
new biography the meanest man in
congress jack brooks and the making of
an american century
on my own
i could never have accomplished as much
as these two intrepid authors
the brooks family
and rightfully all of america
owes these two men a special debt of
gratitude ladies and gentlemen the only
two people who know more about my dad
than i do
tim and brendan mcnulty
tonight is special in another way we are
very fortunate to have with us mr
hendrick hertzberg
he was president's chief white house
speechwriter editor of the new republic
staff writer for the new yorker and a
needed voice of reason even today
he and the authors are going to have
some key observations about chairman
brooks's career and we would like to
thank you rick for being here this
evening
uh as was just mentioned as many of you
know we
a foundation has also been founded in my
father's name and here to tell you more
about it let me introduce
my good friend truly a man for all
seasons and the president of the new
jack brooks foundation mr john bassano
thank you jeb and good evening
i'm thrilled to be here and i really
have two announcements tonight so i have
a pretty easy job but neither of these
would have happened if it wasn't for
jeb's tenacity his passion his
leadership and i want to thank him for
that and recognize that and most of all
thank you for your friendship jeb
i am thrilled to announce the first item
and that is that the jack brooks
foundation is up and running
we're inspired by
and we'll be working to continue the
legacy of hard work and a no-nonsense
non-partisan approach to public policy
the intention of the foundation is to
help as many americans as possible
reconnect with our representative
government and i'm very very proud to be
leading this effort
our first initiative will be to promote
a legacy project
the briscoe center for american history
at the university of texas at austin is
a custodian for the jack brooks
congressional papers
i am very happy to announce that they
have begun a one-year effort to digitize
and make available and searchable online
key legislation championed by chairman
brooks
so we have a lot of activity at the
foundation we're very excited we invite
all of you to stay in touch we'd love to
hear from you
so without further delay
let me begin the conversation about my
friend jack brooks the meanest man in
congress
brendan tim rick please let's get
started
thank you
thank you jeff thank you very much
it's great to be here in the in the
carter library and museum
and perhaps we should have a few words
of welcome indirectly from our host
president jimmy carter
uh when uh
when carter
dedicated the the uh
the i think it was the jack brooks
federal building
he had some nice things to say about
jack brooks
he said
he said i would like to pay particular
particular tribute to the leadership
role of chairman jack brooks he's a
formidable ally to having a tough fight
he hates to lose and rarely does
had it not been for him we wouldn't have
prevailed i'm deeply deeply grateful to
jack
and a little bit
a little bit later our authors uh write
he said somewhat more
um
informally
he they they write
one time in private company
back in plains georgia
carter spoke in plainer language to
dinner companions including curtis
wilkie a well-known journalist for the
boston globe and as it happens a dear an
old friend of mine
carter recalled with admiration how
brooks had been the best ally anyone
could have on capitol hill he's a tough
son of a [ __ ]
and a mean infighter
now jack brooks is a name that
i suspect most uh most c-span viewers
might recognize but the american public
uh
might wonder who who just who jack
brooks was
well on capitol hill
on capitol hill and in the district of
columbia
jack brooks was as famous as elvis
he
and but if you if those of you who
feel a little bit like you might have
heard of him
may remember that the iconic photograph
that was taken on november 22
1963
on the plane that flew
jacqueline kennedy uh
and lyndon johnson among others back to
washington and if you look at the
picture you see over over jackie's left
shoulder
there's jack brooks
so i want to ask you two guys
how did how did this guy go from
i don't know being a newspaper delivery
boy to that airplane
what
what propelled him to those heights well
i think he was really a man of his
generation and
now tom brokaw is dubbed the greatest
generation
he went
from a very hard scrabble life
where his father died when he was 12 and
he worked his way
from paperboy to a
junior reporter for the beaumont
enterprise
he learned
one of the early lessons he had was that
by going and doing a social column he
included all the names of everybody who
was there
and i said well why did you do that and
he said well i knew the editor wouldn't
take out any names and i got paid by the
column inch
and so
that was an early lesson for him and
then he uh he went on to go to the
university of texas
this is in the late 30s early 40s pearl
harbor happened he wanted to sign up for
the marines
a marine recruiter came to campus and at
this time jack was the
editor of the campus student newspaper
so he's the daily texan
i believe it was the uh
he he went uh and the recruiter said
that he was too scrawny he wouldn't make
a marines he should go to the army
and he said no i want to go to the
marines and so he said you know you want
a story in my paper
and said yes
about the recruiting and he said
i don't know if we can get it in for the
next few months
well but maybe if i have that
application i wouldn't be a problem
wouldn't be so
he already was figuring out ways to
negotiate
then he did go to the marines went to
the south pacific for two and a half
years island topping and uh and also
there he began to learn to negotiate
other things like his men needed dry
boots
because of the dampness of the jungle
and and the
they weren't requisitioned
he was able to find a couple of cases of
whiskey
and
suddenly the boots that were supposed to
be
50 boots
with a two in front of it they became
250 pairs of boots
and
so that kind of even though it's maybe
wheeling and dealing it started to
prepare him for congress
and and by the time of in the you know
in air force one with uh jackie kennedy
and and lyndon johnson he had already
been in congress for 10 years so he was
seasoned he was he uh had learned at the
foot of sam rayburn
who was a master of the process of
getting legislation
now
most politicians
with the kind of ambition that jack
brooks had
would yearn to be called mr president
but jack brooks doesn't seem to have
been that guy uh
or nor was he
nor was he yearning to be senator
so-and-so or governor so and so the
title he reveled in
was mr chairman why
why did that why is that
congress
he just wanted to be the best
representative for that district you
know that's the district that he grew up
in those are the people that he knew he
wanted to represent them as well as he
could and
i mean for him that was
that was it you know he had kind of made
it at a young age i think he was 29 when
he first entered congress in 1953
and
he had other opportunities you know he
was going to be tapped potentially this
was the the rumor at the time that he
was going to be tapped for a.g in 1965
once uh
you know his dear friend johnson was
president and he had no interest
he said no you know i'm where i should
be
as you said he wanted to be called mr
chairman you know and he eventually was
mr chairman for
the house
government operations committee from the
74 to 88 and then of course the
judiciary from 88 to
94.
and i think that was that was
the the top of the mountain for him
is to be the chairman of the preeminent
kind of arbiter of of constitutional
principle
yeah one of the things that struck me in
reading the book was
just how close he was to lyndon johnson
um
they
not just as a political ally not just as
somebody who could help him out on
capitol hill but a deeply personal
intimate
relationship i mean to the point where i
got the impression that maybe sometimes
he didn't really want to go over to the
johnsons every night and watch tv and
drink and
have fun
tell tell us a little about the nature
of that relationship which was so unique
i think
all the democratic presidents
found in jack brooks an ally
and somebody that they needed you know
somebody who was their man in the house
and with johnson that was certainly the
case you know johnson knew
the institution of congress as well as
any president ever has and he knew that
jack brooks was the person that he he
needed kind of behind the scenes to to
get the things done that he needed to
get done and brooks still didn't vote
for all the
you know great society legislation i
mean he
he voted for most of it but but not all
and uh and johnson didn't fault him for
that because he knew you know you're not
gonna
not going to push over jack brooks when
you know he's standing on you know his
own principle
and when they got off air force one when
it came back to washington uh brooks
went with johnson to his vice
president's home and
stayed there much of the next week or
two
spending time with them
not only
i mean handling details but
i think as a kind of a personal bulwark
and saying that you're the you know
you're the best man for this now and and
giving him encouragement i i listening
to
the text the uh
tapes at the um
at the johnson library in in austin i
mean it it is amazing to listen to the
two of them
have this
back and forth repartee that that said
these are really
master politicians who know what they're
talking about who know the
other congressmen what they need
what they want to accomplish
and how to how to trade and how to get
their votes
so and they would tick off the names
right off the top of their tongue um for
dozens and dozens of of um
of congressmen and know exactly what
their districts were like and what the
future was and to show the level of
trust
on that day on november 22nd when
they're all huddled in parkland hospital
after the shooting had happened no one
knew if this was a
communist plot if there were other
shooters out there you know there was
this heightened uh
not just anxiety but
you know trauma that everyone was going
through
and when jack brooks finally got to the
hospital he saw
linden there surrounded by a secret
service in a corner with lady bird
and his mobility was limited because you
know this was
he was president as soon as uh
as soon as uh kennedy passed away but
you know this was the you know the
future commander-in-chief so they were
not going to let him go anywhere but
johnson was also you know something that
people don't really know about him is he
was very caring you know very
compassionate individual and he wanted
jackie kennedy to have somebody so he
wanted to send ladybird back to the
the operating room where
kennedy was lying and he couldn't go
himself so we sent jack brooks to to
escort her back there so he was there in
the room with with kennedy's body and
with with the two of them and then they
went and visited with nellie uh connolly
um upstairs
and and then after then they got in the
uh got in he johnson asked
brooks to go with lady bird to the
airport and uh and he
brooks recalled that
that
car ride with the secret service from
parkland to
love field was it the way he said it
he says the fastest i've ever gone we
took off like a like a striped ass zebra
god knows what that
means but it's fast
yeah you get the idea
you know zebras are kind of rare there
yeah and johnson got into the other car
and they uh rufus youngblood was the uh
the big burly uh secret service man he
got in
basically on top of him and then albert
thomas another congressman and i don't
know if it's jim wright or or someone
else but anyway they just they stuff
those cars and took off to the to love
field yeah and brooks kind of seems to
have really come into his own
during
during the johnson administration and in
in
and he had he had an interesting uh he
had an interesting
balance of kind of rhetorical balance
between essentially liberal goals and
liberal ideas
and
concern not exactly conservative
but you know hard-headed
rhetoric and a hard-headed approach
tell us a little bit about how how
how brooks helped give us
the great society
well one of the things that remember he
was a texas democrat
and that's different
and so
you know when when he was very fiscally
conservative he came from a district he
was he was very strong on civil rights
he was very strong on unions these are
you know the different oil refineries
that were right there on the border
between texas and louisiana these are
his constituents
so
he
you know was kind of stood out from a
lot of other
southern democrats or texas democrats
for that
uh what were you i'm sorry what's the
question again
no that's that's uh you know this
combination
which was um which was so
turned into something so creative
of um
liberal goals liberal
liberal
uh hopes liberal
liberal yeah i mean they were men of
their time and i think the
kind of the excitement and the
the benefits of some of the new
new deal legislation had kind of taken
its course and
you know and you had the war and you had
this new generation of legislator coming
back it was you know
hardened and they were
you know they still had these kind of
liberal principles but they were they
were
you know
fired in the what's the phrase
battle
or what
something something along those lines
there's something to hit up chisel on
the anvil of
yes yes yes
yes
that's more relaxed you get what i the
point um
so they were just they were a new type
of a policy maker and i think having
johnson in the in the white house at
that time was
i mean they knew that it was a
beneficial relationship for the both of
them you know they weren't
just buddy buddy they knew that they had
a job to do and that they were they were
valuable to one another as well but
aside from just getting along personally
yeah and they but they were buddy buddy
weren't they and and uh
one gets the impression uh reading this
that it maybe johnson was kind of lonely
and that that he
because he so not just welcomed
uh the brooks's to to the white house
but
he was he was liable to you know call
them up and they had other plans right
and they'd go right over to the white
house and spend they must have spent
hundreds of hours
together
not just talking politics but just sort
of enjoying life
right my
lady bird and charlotte brooks they uh
they watched gunsmoke on tv
uh you know i mean it was just like two
couples that are getting together all
the time
um so they
yeah now they they enjoyed each other's
company um and there was no question of
that and and brooks i think for a
president that's always called like the
loneliest job
and so you need someone or people but at
least someone who isn't trying to get
anything for his personal gain he might
not have
you know shied away from getting uh
something for beaumont but
but he was never
anything after anything for himself
uh and i think that's something that
presidents need one thing that he
learned from rayburn was you don't talk
to the press
back you know in that day you did not
you know they had this board of
education which is where all the kind of
insider
the leadership from from both the
republicans and the democrats would meet
in the speaker's chambers after
five o'clock and he would have um
you know they would drink a scotch
together and kind of discuss politics
surely it was a bourbon
it was bourbon and then they decided to
switch the scotch because it but for
health reasons
but
yeah so so he learned that from from
rayburn um so it was an interesting
education that that he got yeah rayburn
was raven still speaker yeah it was
until 1716. yeah so it was a real it was
a real uh
this
we were we belonged to texas didn't we
in that there was a big texas delegation
and
and it was but it was those three
rayburn johnson and brooks that kind of
steered the
conversation
uh and so and they understood
what levers to pull
and they and the direction they steered
it in was a lot different from what we
now think of as
what texas
yeah what texas wants it's different
today
why was he why was he so friendly to
civil rights
how much how do you know what the what
the racial composition of this district
was
uh it was much more mixed than the rest
of texas yeah i mean you had so much
industry uh just in this little corner
and you had
you know
you know kind of migrant workers coming
for for generations to that corner so
i think he grew up in a very different
kind of community his yeah his district
had you know very kind of traditional um
uh whites uh and
they had a video or was a town in his
district that where the
video
and where the grand dragon for the ku
klux klan lived and that was in his
district as well um and so you had this
real mix of people
uh and political outlooks and not only
did he have to steer but you know
through that but he also um
really believed in civil rights he
believed that that was it he there was a
time when the
the
after the in response to the brown
versus board of education where they i
think it was
84
southern democrat
congressmen and 19 senators
signed this
you know southern manifesto which didn't
say they wanted to continue
segregation but that was the purpose of
it and he refused to sign it um there
were a few others i think
maybe a dozen that including his friend
jim wright that also refused um but it
was a dozen in texas or it doesn't in
the south
south yeah out of one out of
more than 100 i imagine this was uh it
was about 82
that that signed it and uh and about a
dozen that that did not and then 19
senators signed it as well so 82 out of
430 well some people said
that and that's
defined as the 11 original confederate
states
did he did he ever
did he ever had
did he ever think about running for
for a statewide office or national
office it feels like from the book it
feels like
he really didn't give that
a thought yeah he said he was never
tempted at that um
and it just didn't come didn't occur to
him that he would and so that
consequently he didn't care if some
reporters from california called up they
he would talk to him but he didn't care
about the press
uh getting anything special from him
that would elevate his national stature
he cared about this district uh in
beaumont and and round
and he cared about
the power of the chairmanship in
washington
but he got an endorsement from the new
york times in 1966
and i asked him for a comment about it
afterwards and he was like
i don't know i guess they like my uh
you know my policy about uh you know
shipping in the intercoastal uh waterway
now
when uh like how many presidents did you
say he worked under 10. and people
learned very quickly not to make the
mistake that he worked under 10
presidents worked with 10 presidents
yeah
he
now had it how did
i get the feeling too from the way from
his military experience where where he
he knew the rule book
but he played by the real rule book i
mean he played by the rule book of human
nature
and that that was some that was kind of
the way he
he
became a became this effective
legislator as he did yeah he looked well
good he learned where he could bend the
rules like adding the two in front of
the 50 to get more boots
he also learned that he
as an officer they were staging to uh to
go back to guam at one point and he was
supposed to sleep with his troops off on
this ship that was off the coast of i
don't know if they were still in okinawa
or where but he realized pretty quickly
that he could sleep on shore and you
know in this officer's
mess hall and in the company of
of a red cross nurse that he had come to
know
named kitty
and he found out that uh if he woke up
just at a certain time he could
basically leap off of the dock and on to
the cargo netting of the departing ship
uh transport ship that went out to where
the troops were sleeping crawl up like a
buccaneer hop over without anyone seeing
and be back in time for morning
some of his compatriots some of his
fellow soldiers saw and they cheered him
on
yeah
he didn't consider uh
a military a long-term military career
no he was already behind the gun i mean
he had started a little bit too late he
so one of the joys of doing the research
for this book was we
we found a cache of letters that he had
written home to his uh his family and
friends and uh all the letters that he
had received
and then he then sent back to his sister
and
told her to dutifully uh file them all
away
so he was a bit of a pack grad and he
had these for uh you know i guess for 70
70 some years packed away and
we're talking about him about what age
this is
45 so we've been 23 and i think he
thought that he would only make captain
but you know by a certain age and by
then all the people that were captain
were you know
he was just kind of behind the
trajectory and he and he fully expected
to
participate in the invasion of of japan
didn't oh definitely he was very
relieved um
because they were in the
in the preparation for it and he thought
that they were um
they talked about the casualty
estimates for american troops as high as
60 percent yeah and
they were all
very anxious
when truman dropped the bomb on
hirashima and nagasaki they were
relieved
and
that even came up in a in a meeting they
had in
in beaumont during a campaign
and
brooks was very outspoken he you didn't
have to agree with him but he would tell
you what he thought and when it came to
time for a question came up he said well
they should have dropped a third
and
and his staff audible gasped around this
staff it's just like
but
but they looked
and the cameras had just been turned off
but in those letters too
i mean he was the classic overachiever
so he was friends with all of kind of
the
student body class presidents and the
you know the secret society clubs at ut
and they all exchanged letters about
what they were going to do after school
and he knew that he wanted to come back
and get his
get his uh license and run for congress
really i think he knew that he had a
role to play as a congressman he
um
you know and i think we're still in the
60s but as as time you know went on and
he learned the kind of
the levers and you know the the
machinations of congress he knew
how he could use his position and and
you know he did it through the
government operations committee and the
judiciary and as kind of
the time came he was
the person you know perfectly positioned
to to really i mean the next biggest
thing that came up was obviously the uh
the impeachment uh hearings
we'll get we'll get to that in a second
he did run he did run for
didn't he run first for the legislature
he was in the texas legislature for two
terms two terms and but he always had
his eye on well what he wanted his goal
there was to get lamar college which was
in uh beaumont to make it a state-funded
university and so he
um tried and tried and then it failed
and then the next term he came back and
tried some more
and
and
told people what effect because all
these
you know students from that area had to
go away to go to college i mean in order
to get a full degree which is like a
two-year college yeah and and he really
he cared about that uh for the his
constituents and so
he uh he did it and the votes came and
they missed by a mark you know margin of
one or two
and uh then he decided well he was going
to uh
he was going to take all these
legislators on a trip uh on a
down river and have a party
and he said when they
went down the river they were it was
lamar college when it came back up the
river it was lamar university
and so
but i think that's the kind of you know
why a lot of people have never heard of
him is because he did things that were
important but didn't you know get lots
of publicity for instance light bulbs
at that point
and and i'm not sure exactly what year
there was a light bulb
now we're fast forwarding to while he's
in congress in back in congress now yes
and he's he's getting say why did light
bulbs burn out so much there's no reason
to because we know they can last much
much longer and so he pushed and got
legislation that made them change the
way they make light bulbs so we have
lights that stay on longer and don't
cost as much
um it was actually yelling at an aide
because an aide was up switching the
light bulbs again and his like
expletive
why do these light bulbs burn out so
fast because the technology hadn't
changed since you know
the first light bulb yeah well
the other thing was that he was a
he uh
he also cared about other issues that
were important to people like uh for
instance computers
yeah you know the whole notion of having
computers uh the government
had this
basically they or ibm had a monopoly and
the government was um
paying renting them and he said why
aren't why aren't we buying them so we
don't have to keep paying the same rent
on this over and over and he had the
change so that now there's much more
free enterprise
with the computers now there was a lot
of other didn't he do
a lot to
bring about the computer age
you know for a texas congressman well
that was the original brooks act in 65
he took this report that all of the uh
computer computing specialists um
in the gsa had had compiled and saying
this is what the government needs to do
you know we use all these disparate
systems that don't talk to each other
you know they don't
we've got you know downtime in the va
you know we've got a surplus of work to
do over in uh you know the health
education and welfare department and he
said okay well
we're gonna we're gonna write a bill and
if these companies want to
sell or lease to the federal government
they all have to be interoperable that
was the term you need to be able to you
know write your code and have it play on
someone else's machine and vice versa
and this really set the stage of a level
playing ground for
you know the modern i.t industry and at
this point
ibm had 75 percent market share and they
basically told the federal government
okay this is what we're going to sell
you this is how you're going to use it
you know this is how much we're going to
charge you
but which is what a monopoly does
there's also i think a lot of relevance
to today
in brooks's life story
and that is something that when
as a congressman he
served on a on a panel
that was impeaching a federal judge
so he had to learn the kind of the rules
of impeachment um and
then he well you can take over the story
from there but
well this was w.o douglas 1970. this was
a
federal judge who
liberal federal judge who had
accepted speaking fees william o douglas
the supreme court justice
the great liberal supreme court justice
yes so brooks was put on a select panel
meaning congressmen and senators
to
basically decide if there was reasonable
you know evidence that an impeachment
investigation should be brought into
this this case
and they spent months on it and finally
came out with a report that said no
there's not enough evidence you know but
that was 1970 and then 1974 comes around
and he's the only person on the
judiciary with any impeachment
experience
so this was
and people think that you know the
reason why
those impeachment hearings were kicked
into the judiciary was because tip tip
o'neill who was i think majority leader
at the time
had such a rapport with with jack brooks
and and had so much faith in his his
rigor
that he wanted him to kind of take the
reins and even though jack brooks was
not chairman he wasn't you know the next
most senior member um
but he knew that jack brooks was really
the the driving force behind the
judiciary and he would
he would give it his all and he and he
got together with his staff and
there's a there was a couple of dozen
possibly possible impeachment articles
and he said no we want to get it down to
three to five really strong ones and
that's what they did
in a back room um or
a broom closet some call it but um
but they got this list together
um
and they brought it out gave it to paul
sarbanes who was a new senator um from
maryland and
he read the impeachment articles at the
same time that i read before that he
hadn't read before and
and
that
if it hadn't been for the smoking gun
tape
that's where it would have gone to these
impeachment articles
but instead nixon resigned the next week
but he he reduced the
he reduced the possible articles to a
more to a manageable few there were 35
congressmen who had
who had um submitted some you know
individual resolution for impeachment
and
among those 35 resolutions there was
essentially 52 charges
which 17 were just kind of spurious and
thrown out by uh by the congressional
leader by the democratic leadership and
then the rest were kicked into the
judiciary say okay you know you've
started this hearing and uh
and basically you know
you're not to investigate anymore you're
not to investigate the actual facts
you're basically to take
the evidence from the senate um
the watergate
[Music]
hearings and you're to basically
determine if from that material there's
impeachable offenses so
it's just sat you know with chairman
peter rodino from
from new york they just kind of sat and
he and the special prosecutor john doerr
that that he he selected
they didn't really they didn't want to
make a mistake you know they knew that
the you know the world and the nation's
eyes were on them and they this was a
present from the opposing party so they
didn't want to seem partisan or
overzealous so they their
their method was to go slow and you know
have everything out in the open and you
know bring everyone in and and brooks
was like no like let's get this done
forget about the optics forget about you
know
i mean have a fair process but basically
let's get this started so after six
months of virtually no action he said
okay i'm gonna do it so he he took those
yeah maybe about 15 17 different um of
the most
kind of critical uh charges and kicked
him out to to his committee member to
his staff members and said you know
let's see what we can come up with and
he came up with 10.
and they only brought three before the
committee but they only needed one
and they and what they really i mean it
was
kick-starting this to say you know um we
need to get something done we've been
going on for months and months
and he didn't want it to be another long
drawn-out legalistic flight fight over
this so he tried to make sure that the
articles of impeachment
dealt with constitutional issues and not
like what does this mean in the in the
law and you could fight it out and
appeal it to the supreme court he wanted
it to be a strict constitutional uh
impeachment issue yeah the language i
mean you can see you can go to briscoe
center for american history at ut and
see the drafts that he went through and
they're just redlined and you know he
was crossed out conspired and written
and acted in concert with
you know
he didn't want any loaded words in that
yeah and withheld vital evidence and he
crosses out vital you know so just
withheld evidence so he was he was very
exact
it sounds like he was a sort of a
newspaper editor
he's that could be
that's and i he hadn't lost that
uh and law school had helped yeah and
and so at the daily texan yeah
so
so it's no surprise i guess that nixon
called him what the executioner the
executioner and and how how do we know
that he did that is he did he do that in
public or did he do that he did that in
private and it's kind of uh we've looked
you know
relentlessly for
for specific you know first source uh
mentions of this and i think we just
have to chalk it up to political lore
because everyone knows about it i mean
it was in newspapers back in the day um
that people were talking about this and
i think it's because he was the force
behind the the impeachment hearings he
forced rodino's hand when rodina was
wishy-washy about oh well should we you
know we already sent him a subpoena he
doesn't want to follow it so what can we
do so he said oh we'll write him a
letter again you know and and you know
demand that he comply um
and i think maybe the real reason is
because uh right before um
the
the articles were were released
rodino called all the congress the
democratic members of of the committee
together and he said well okay so
what are we going to do
and brooks kind of probably took a cigar
out of his mouth and he said well all
we've got to do is decide are we going
to shoot them or hang them
yep so
that might also be one
and prior to this too when
after uh agnew resigned and ford
was um chosen to be the new vice
president
brooks had enough foresight to say let's
ask these questions and he had a list of
52 questions to put to ford because if
ford
did become the vice president which was
pretty obvious he was
and then nixon left then ford would
become president indeed so he wanted
ford on record saying that what's an
impeachable offense or if this president
did this you know did he deserve to stay
in office it was light of the public lie
to congress falsify tax records
i mean 52 separate items you wanted
answers to so he was thinking ahead how
did ford ford was uh was minority leader
then how did he feel about this grilling
well you know ford later wrote a note to
him saying that
thanking him he said
you were tough but fair but great
and oh great but fair is that tough but
but tough but great tough but great but
fair
yeah
he's my editor too
huh
um
i keep going back to because i'm so
curious about it the the that personal
relationship going back to
lbj
and um
that
it was it was almost like they were the
best best friends or the family that the
couples were best friends
um
do you know that did business get done
during these social
evenings which were met which were a lot
lots and lots and lots of them weren't
they just he didn't want to watch tv
alone i think well i don't think johnson
watched gunsmoke um i think
the i think politics was their
socialization
they that's what they talked about um
and that's what they enjoyed talking
about
they would go through and and uh
just kind of blue sky what things they
were going to you know suggest and how
much support they'd get for it and the
letters between them you know thanking
each other for for their supporter our
legion you know you can see all these
papers too at the briscoe center
but johnson famously said that the only
congressman that he was afraid of was
jack brooks
this is while they were
did they did did they did they ever
clash did they ever disagree they did
the the details are a little murky but
it was over the appointment of a federal
judge in the 50s and they didn't talk
from any justice or a
lower court judge a lower court
but yeah somebody wanted somebody
appointed and and somebody wanted
somebody else so that was what the tiff
was over
how did he get how did he get along with
ford as president
he liked ford because he thought he
could just have his way i think he
thought yeah he's great you know i mean
he liked ford a lot because ford was a
decent man and he kind of
represented a lot of what he really
disliked personally about nixon
and you know he'd worked with with ford
for for a long time
up until that point so he respected him
but but he also he fought him tooth and
nail over the budget ford came into
into the white house with you know
runaway inflation and
and
i mean there are all these defense
projects that were kind of running
running amok and he wanted to
um do a lot of kind of interesting
things with that with the budget that
had support but uh but maybe weren't the
best idea and you know the one
congressman that stood in his way was
jack brooks and he said no we're not
going to do this you know we're not
going to we're not going to continue
some of these programs that might be
popular but are wrong for
for the for the federal government
and all publications i mean
jimmy carter wrote in his memoir about
how you know difficult it was at first
dealing with brooks uh he wanted
reorganization and
and brook said that was the prerogative
of congress it wasn't for him to do and
it took him a while to warm up to each
other yeah who did who did brooks did
rook support any candidate in in that
race before the nomination
not that i'm aware of
so he i don't know
yeah but he campaigned for carter
yeah he was a partisan democrat no
question about it that yeah
when ford had another nickname for him
so about the budget
brooks actually did talk to the media
quite a bit about that it was national
news and he said you know well we're
going to do to this budget what we do to
rattlesnakes in texas
kill them when they're young
so that got him the name snake killer
who went from the executioner to snake
killer to
mr chairman
i think i think that's a
good point to
to break for a second and and get some
of the questions from the audience here
um derek has the the microphone as i say
he he'll hold it in front of you anyone
with a question down here
any any questions
we'll start we'll start right in front
hi
thank you for being here as lovely to
listen i wanted to know if you guys had
any personal stories um that you loved
particularly i love the kind of personal
anecdotes are so lovely and if there are
any that you thought um we should know
about that didn't kind of make it into
the
the conversation already
you want to
well what i like is that he he was such
a hard worker and he demanded
you know just absolute discipline and
and you know hard work from his staff
and he was he was a tough boss i mean
people loved him for it but he was a
tough boss and i remember reading this
one story about a young staffer
who was in his office and just
you know just absolutely tickled that
the congressman the chairman had invited
him over to the house one one saturday
you know presumably for for lunch and so
he drives to the house in mclean
virginia and knocks on the door and the
chairman opens up and says oh good boy
you're here meet me around back i've got
some brush for you to clear
chairman of committees were like gods as
someone said and
and they could uh they the other
chairman
you know
bowed to their wishes about legislation
uh and so if they wanted something
they were the experts in that field um
the there is uh
the one one story i like about uh
brooks is it's a different time now
people
in washington they don't live in the
same neighborhoods
some of them don't even live in
washington they just commute back to
their
you know districts and spend two or
three days in d.c
before people would go the kids would go
to the same school the you know the
usually it would be wives not spouses
but wives who would be in some social
programs together and so um
it was something that was a natural way
there was god knows they were partisan
but they were
it didn't didn't have this era of
personal destruction
um you know and
so anyway rux lived in this uh the
brooks family in this cul-de-sac uh in
virginia and um and uh
and
uh one of the former governors of
virginia lived down
down the block and um
and uh
strom thurman uh is a well-known
segregationist and uh he was about two
or three doors down jeb would know for
sure
one day strong is also besides being a
segregationist he was
known for marrying a woman 42 years his
senior his junior
and
and so one day strom and brooks were
walking to get toward each other on the
sidewalk and
and uh
thurman very proudly said
you know
we're having a baby
and brooks looked at him and
paused
looked up and said
who do you suspect
[Laughter]
other questions yes
well i'd like to just go back to you
know you had talked about the strong
relationship between johnson and brooks
but from the way that you've described
it it seems like they had very different
ambitions
and of course johnson had many masters
from brown and root to
you know to uh
russell and all these others that he was
working to try to gain influence
and move to a higher office
but
it seems to me that brooks seemed
more like rayburn
in so far as he
wanted to be
um
you know first among his peers
in the house
but what i want to know is i mean those
were very rough and tumble times in the
democratic party in particular with such
a coalition of very different
factions
did you identify
masters that brooks had you know
interests that he had to serve and then
beyond that if you could talk a little
bit about his eventual uh fall and loss
of his final election sure
i i might go to the last thing first
so it was
94 the
crime bill
that president clinton wanted
brooks
had shepherded it and
different forms
he knew and he believed that it was
important to separate them because
the assault weapons ban was part of it
and he knew that was a killer issue
this was an omnibus bill which meant it
was like 10 different massive bills
combined into one huge tough on crime
bill too
it was yeah which is now playing out
even now
and
besides the assault weapons yeah the
incarceration which
was you know disastrous effect
um
but i mean at that point in this is 94
clinton was insistent and in clinton's
memoir he talks about this and and
says he should have listened to brooks
and some others um because
they said this is going to kill us
at the polls and the assault weapons ban
specifically yeah that one
and so
uh but clinton said they wanted it all
together so they voted for it and uh 50
democratic congressmen lost their seats
including tom foley who was the only
speaker of the house currently to lose
his seat um
so
that's what you know the the
blowback from that in 94
um
had brooks brooks who was an nra member
he had been you know like i said a texas
democrat he wasn't uh um kind of being
soft on anything about he he believed in
the second amendment that he already
believed in the nra the nra invited him
to be a keynote speaker at their annual
conference four years prior
and he was also
host of a congressional um
not a turkey hunt but like a skeet shoot
out in fairfax virginia every year i
mean he was
as far as you know kind of
gun supporting uh congressman went he
was he was the guy and uh the lesson
learned from that election was you know
you can't slip up once with
with that particular lobby
question over here
are you talking about
his ability to get along with the
democrats
but you haven't talked about his
ability to get along with the
republicans
yeah actually
there were i mean not all republicans
but there were a good number of
republicans that we counted as his
friends
uh and
even if they were opposed on some
legislation
um
he uh
he was always willing to work with him
the
bob dole story you want to
sure
well that's a lot better just just one
thing about when there was a
a meeting between the house leadership
and the senate leaders the the house
wanted a bill to go through the senate
the senate people led by bob dole wanted
this legislation approved so it could
move on and so they made a deal
um
and
but but dole said
but i want that in writing and from your
leaders and your leadership and and then
as he was leaving someone said well
what about brooks in writing and he said
nah
brooks's word is good
and then well and then brooks
called got back to his office and called
up dole and said i don't know what he
said exactly but probably like damn it
don't make me look bad in front of my
leadership you know
don't compliment me
you know
tip o'neill
was famous for his ability to get along
with republicans
for example
president reagan
uh
what what examples do you have of of um
mr brooks getting along with
this side
well he eventually agreed with uh with
ford for example on the budget and ford
changed his budget as a result of
brooks's input
reagan invited him to the oval office
you know to discuss legislative matters
again and again
herbert walker did herbert walker always
was also very
very uh
good about referring to him as the
chairman i mean he was always
deferential when brooks was in the room
i mean another thing that i mean if we
had more time to to write another couple
chapters about this book or if there are
any other future or congressional
researchers out there
there was a guy i think he's from new
york
a republican named frank horton and he
was the ranking member on the house
government operations committee for
years and years
and between the two of them
the number of marquee just
life
changing bills that the two of them
sponsored together and pushed through
congress is just amazing
the inspectors general act um the
paperwork reduction act which reduced uh
federal you know bureaucracy um the
consumer protection act which
eventually failed but i mean it failed
in that congress with uh with carter you
know um but but it was
eventually passed um
so i mean he and frank horton were as
prolific as any
any pair of uh
you know of a democrat and a republican
in congress during that time
sorry i'd like to take a prerogative to
ask one question of my own
one thing that i think get gets lost in
the fun stories is is the hard work of
congress there's a
comment in the book about workhorses
versus show horses and one of the
reasons we don't know so much about jack
brooks is that he was one of the
workhorses
and he was doing the actual job of a
representative democrat or republican
by saving the country money
i know there were a lot of brooks bills
and a lot of things you mentioned the
ibm one were there other aspects where
his work just as a legislator helped the
country as a whole
well he always saw
the federal government as
as an agent for good and he saw the the
leverage and the vast kind of reach that
the government had as a way of
of kind of bullying private industry
into acting well
or producing the type of products or
services that that people needed
he
i'm trying to think we're yeah he he
certainly didn't believe like reagan
that the government was he was the enemy
he thought the government is what was
helping people and you know maybe not
always perfectly but
things can be perfected work and be
better uh it was like but it wasn't the
same feeling that that
you have to be against the government he
was totally for the government
i think i'm going to wrap this up with
one final question
if
because you all know and has studied
jack brooks so much if he were to step
into the democratic caucus
right now
these days what advice would he give the
democratic caucus about the way
things are done
you mean apart from the blistering
language
i think a really
an interesting insight into what he
might do today is is what nancy pelosi
is doing today because she was in office
for about six or eight years while he
was still there and she didn't serve on
his committees but
but she definitely looked up to him as a
mentor so i think some of the acts that
she's doing where she's not responding
to the 24-hour news cycle and she and
some of the more
maybe younger firebrands
you know right away she's taking a more
cautious approach to making sure that
that everything is done correctly i
think that's one
indication as to what he might suggest i
mean he was a stickler for the details
and he he knew the issues and
legislation everything inside and out
better than anyone there was a quote
from a
article in texas monthly from the early
70s and and one of those things was uh
one of the quotes about brooks was you
know there's two things about that make
a politician
effective or not on the hill there's how
strong is their
substantive position and then how much
elbow grease can they put into it and
jack brooks had both you know
that's probably here can i say can i say
one uh one more thing as as a reader my
my
prerogative as a reader i just want to
congratulate you two on the brilliance
of this title i think it's a wonderful
title
and
it's uh when you think about it a little
bit it's got so many multiple meanings
yeah there's that guy there's like
there's that that
monster with a cigar you know ready to
ready to slice
the head off whoever he's questioning or
whatever government wasted he's he's
but but the word with that word mean it
also suggests the golden mean
it also suggests methods ways of doing
things and he he was able to do so much
so much good
so much good of the kind that's now
sneered at as government
waste
and he he he he sought the means to get
these things done at the lowest possible
price and the highest possible quality
and um
we need a bit more of that
he took that title which his colleagues
gave him about meanest man in congress
and he took it as a point of pride uh
you know that it was he was tough
he also
corporate
ceos and pentagon generals and other
depart federal department heads would be
before his committee and they would they
would mutter
that s.o.b
and
and brooks told the staff
well what they really mean is sweet old
brooks
i told you it would be a fascinating
evening and it has been and it's not
over yet acapella books has copies of
the meanest man in congress for sale in
the lobby i encourage you to get it the
holidays are coming up just a thought
the mcnulty's are going to be signing
copies of them out front and there's
also some dessert and coffee for you as
well so please join me in thanking them
all one more time
thank you